BEFORE WE COMMENCE I SUPPOSE I
SHOULD NOTE THAT THIS IS THE
VERY FIRST HEARING IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED OF THE- STREET
BUILDING WHICH MAKES US ALL PLAN
COLDER'S. YOU CAN LOOK THAT UP.
ALL RIGHT. SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD AFTERNOON RESPONSE THE COVE
IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO PROTECT
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IN HERE TO SOCIAL TO
SING FACE COVERING GUIDELINES
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY JUSTICE
NOR PRODUCTS IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC TUESDAY OF AXES
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVEN'T BEEN
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC OF THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCE REQUIREMENTS
WILL ALLOW WE WILL BE USING
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO AS FAR
MULLIN DAY. PROVINCIALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AN
AXIS BECAUSE POSAR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE. SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE ONE
ONE FOUR ZERO FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCE OR IS WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WEBSITES
WHEN MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATE
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME
AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER WHICH MAY TAKE A MOMENT.
WHAT YOU SEE THE LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATE CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER
ATTHAT TIME YOU'LL BE ON MUTE
IT NEARLY READY ADDRESSED THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER
FOR US TO HEA YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FOOD FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE VICE YOU'RE
WATCHING OR HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY NAY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTION MUTED- ALL
RIGHT WE ONLY HAVE ONE BILL ON
TODAY'S AGENDA BUT BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY PROCEED- LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. BELL CHIEF
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL. THE
ROLL FOR PRESERVES DIVISION
QUORUM. FOR PURPOSES OF
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM. A CENTER-
BURKE YEAH. AND I'M BURKE IS
HERE- CENTER BURGESS. CENTER
CABALLERO. SACRAMENTO HERE
SENATOR DOCILE CENTER GONZALEZ
CENTER GONZALEZ IS HERE CENTER
HERTZBERG SENATOR JONES. SENATOR
JONES IS HERE CENTER LAYERED.
SENATOR STERN SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI SENATOR CASKEY IS HERE
SENATOR WIENER. SENATOR WIENER
IS PRESENT- SURE YOU HAVE A
QUORUM AND I KNOW THE PRESIDENT
OF HERTZBERG AS WELL. ALL RIGHT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON YOU BEEN
A PATIENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE- AB SEVEN SIX
NINE FLOORS YOURS. THANK YOU AND
BEFORE YOU GO I JUST DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS ARE GROWING LIKE OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS IDEAS TO TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL
PERMITTED TO WITNESSES WILL BE
ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES. ALL THOSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS THEIR NAME AFFILIATION
POSITION ON THE MEASURE. ALL
RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THIS TEAM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN SIXTY NINE WHICH
AUTHORIZES UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY TO A CORPORATION
TO CONDUCT ITS ANNUAL
SHAREHOLDER MEETING REMOTELY
GENERALLY CALIFORNIA LAW
REQUIRES A CALIFORNIA
CORPORATIONS MUST HAVE SOME TYPE
OF IN PERSON COMPONENT TO THEIR
ANNUAL MEETINGS BUT SINCE THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC THE
NEWSOME ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE TAKEN STEPS TO
PROVIDE COMPANIES MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO CONDUCT THESE
MEETINGS REMOTELY WHILE THE
VIRUS POSES. A PUBLIC HEALTH
RISK SO FAR THIS FLEXIBILITY HAS
BEEN A SUCCESS AND REMOTE
SHAREHOLDER MEETINGS HAVE LED TO
INCREASED PARTICIPATION
UNFORTUNATELY THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT ALLOWS THE FOR REMOTE
SHAREHOLDER MEETINGS WILL EXPIRE
MARCH THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AB SEVEN SIXTY NINE SIMPLY
EXTENDS THE CURRENT POLICY UNTIL
THE SUMMER WELL WE'RE ALL
HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
FACING OUT THE TEMPORARY PUBLIC
HEALTH MEASURES WE HAVE PUT IN
PLACE JUST THIS MORNING I READ
ABOUT NEW SPIKES IN COVERT
NINETEEN CASES ABROAD. WITH THIS
IN MIND IT IS APPROPRIATE THAT
WE GRANT ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS WHICH
WILL ALLOW SUCH MEETINGS TO BE
HELD SAFELY ULTIMATELY AB SEVEN
SIXTY NINE WILL HELP PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH BY PROVIDING A
SIMPLE EXTENSION OF THE POLICY
THAT HAS ALREADY PROVEN TO BE
VERY SUCCESSFUL WITH THAT AND TO
THE CHERUB LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
WITNESS CAN CAUSE REGIONAL. VP
AT SEPARATE. THANK YOU MUST
COUNTER MEMBERS CAN'T TELL YOU
BEFORE YOU BEGIN BUT LET ME ALSO
REPEAT THE NUMBER APPARENTLY
DIDN'T DISPLAY ON THE SCREEN IS
LIKE HEAD INFORM THE PUBLIC SO-
FOR THOSE OF YOU WATCHING AND
LISTENING I'M GONNA REPEAT THE
NUMBER AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE. PUBLIC COMMENT THE
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. IN
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE
ONE ONE. FOUR ZERO AND- WHEN
YOU. BASICALLY YOU DIAL THOSE
NUMBERS YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY
THE MODERATOR DIAL ONE. ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION SCOUSE
PLEASURES. YEAH THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS THANK YOU-
KEPT CALCIUM HALF OF SAN DIEGO
GAS ELECTRIC AND SOCALGAS SEMPRA
ENERGY. WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I WON'T REPEAT WHAT
THE AUTHORS ARE DISTRICTS STATED
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS HAVING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR KRAUSS-
ALSO I BELIEVE WE HAVE- RONAK
DAYLAMI. THE CORRECT. YES SIR.
ALL RIGHT I THINK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS ARE NOT A
LOT OF POLICY ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
I'LL BE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY NINE WE THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING FORWARD THIS BILL
WHICH PROVIDE ME A FLEXIBILITY
INSURANCE TO BUSINESSES THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO CONDUCT
REMOTE SHAREHOLDER MEETING FOR
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS FOLLOWING
ASPIRATION THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER. IT GETS BETTER
THAN ANY CONFLICTS THAT HAPPEN
TO THE PANDEMIC IS A CONSTANT
SHIFT IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
STATUS IN THE EVOLVING SOCIETAL
AND BUSINESS BEST PRACTICES FOR
RESPONDING TO CURRENT PUBLIC
HEALTH NEEDS MY ALL ABOUT CASH
MONEY BY PHONE HERE TAKE EXTRA
NOT ONLY HOW MUCH THINGS HAVE
CHANGED IN THE CAPITAL TO GET
STARTED COMING NINETEEN HOW MUCH
THINGS REMAIN UNCHANGED HERE
THAN AN APPLICANT CAUTION IS
WHAT IT IS TO MAKE CHANGES TO
TERM PRACTICALLY BEEN FINE OR
NORMAL. I THANK WE BELIEVE A
FLEXIBILITY CREATED BY SEVENTY
NINE BUILT EXTREMELY HELPFUL AND
LOOKS PRUDENT IN THE TRANSITION
PERIOD FOLLOWING EXECUTIVE ORDER
ONLY. AFTER I THOUGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OUR OTHERS
TO TEST. IN SO. OF AB SO. SIX
NINE IF YOU APPROACH MICROPHONE
. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ACTUALLY JOHNSON ON
BEHALF OF PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
THIS ROOM ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED IN
SUPPORT- ALL RIGHT NOW MOVING TO
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE- MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PROP INDIVIDUALS WHICH
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
SIX NINE. I'LL GO AHEAD AND
QUEUE THEM UP PLEASE. THANK YOU
AGAIN IT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT. THIS MEASURE AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE KNOWING
QUEUING UP. ALL RIGHT- LET'S NOW
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION I'M NOT
AWARE O ANY OPPOSITION BUT IF
THERE IS OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED IF YOU APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE- SAYING NO ONE
MOVING FORWARD. ALL RIGHT LET'S
TURN TO- THE PHONE LINES NOW. TO
QUEUE UP THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVEN SIX NINE MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. SEVEN SIX
NINE. THANK YOU AGAIN ONE ZERO
IF ELECTED EXPRESSED OPPOSITION
. AND WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING UP
ALL RIGHT LET'S LET'S NOW TURN
TO THE COMMITTEE- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SIR QUITE YES CENTER
HERTZBERG YEAH I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS PURCHASED MY RECOLLECTION
IN THE OLD DAYS OF- FORMING A
LOT OF CORPORATIONS. I MEAN IS
THIS REALLY A PROBLEM BECAUSE
UNDER THE CORPORATE LAW. YOU CAN
JUST FILE UNANIMOUS WRITTEN
CONSENT. YOU CAN BE ALWAYS BEEN
THE CASE TOOK OUR I'M FOR IT IS
FAR TO GIVE YOU. ON THE QUESTION
A JUST CURIOUS AS TO. IT IN THIS
COUNTRY TONY ARE SOME OF
DIVISION IN THE BOARD'S THIS
WEEK A BIG PROBLEM BECAUSE- IN
CORPORATE BOARD. WE HAVE SUMMER
IN URGES LET'S JUST. IN THE LIKE
ON THE COURT CO- CAN'T THE- H.
NOT A PROBLEM IS IT WHAT THE
WHAT'S THE REAL PROBLEM WITH
OUR- IT IS UNIT. CAN OF ALL THE-
SENSATA UP ITS OPERATION COULD
CREATE A HUNDRED SOMETHING LIKE
THAT YOU MEMBER THAT THE- MISTER
FROM LIKE. YEAH. YEAH WE WOULD
HAVE TO COURSE ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS- ALL OUR SHARE. AND
UNANIMOUS. TO DO IT. WELL THAT'S
FOR SURE BEFORE COURT FOR THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS MEETING IT'S
PRETTY SIMPLE YEAH BUT WORD IN
THIS BILL IS ABOUT THE ANNUAL
SHAREHOLDER MEETING. I SEE. YOU
HAVE TO GET ALL THE ATTENTION
DEFICIT OF ALL SHAREHOLDERS
YEAH. THAT'S A BIG PROBLEM OKAY
I DID. MANAGE FAIR IT'S EASY
IT'S SIMPLE TODAY'S WEATHER JUST
CURIOUS AS TO. WHAT THE REAL
ISSUE IS HERE MAKES SENSE OKAY
THANKYOU ARE YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS BUT JUST AS A NOTE
SENATORS WERE MY STANCE REMINDED
ME THAT. I SHOULD NOT BEGIN ANY
SENSE IN THE OLD DAYS STARTING.
RIGHT NOW IS WHAT THEY SAID
YEAH. SO ALL RIGHT. SO ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS IS THERE A MOTION.
CENTER MORE DISPOSABLE ALL
RIGHT- WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE SOME
OF THEM GRAYSON RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND. I BOTH THINK ARGUE
CONSIDERATION. MANY COUNTY. THIS
IS AB SEVEN SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON WITH A
MOTION BY SENATOR BORJAS THE
MOTION IS TO PASS- BURKE I AM
BERG FIVE. BURGESS BY CARRIE
ADAM CARRY IT OUT I DID ALSO GET
US SO I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG FIVE JONES
. JONES I LAYERED HI LAYERED HI
STERN WHITE HOUSE SKI WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WIENER AYE WIENER
AYE YOU HAVE TEND TO ZERO WITH
ALL MEMBERS VOTING ALREADY THANK
YOU MA'AM CHIEF COUNSEL THE BILL
IS OUT JUST AS A REMINDER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AS A REMINDER COMMITTEE
WILL WE WILL- BE MEETING NEXT
TUESDAY- AND BE MEETING OF FOUR
SUCCESSIVE TUESDAYS FOR. SEVERAL
WEEKS WE'VE WE'VE GOT QUITE A
ROBUST BILL LOW THIS YEAR AND I
KNOW THAT MAKES YOU ALL HAPPY
BECAUSE YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT
BEING BORED SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR TEN DAY.